us coal stocks moved higher today after
the US Supreme Court decided that the
Environmental Protection Agency did not
properly consider the cost of new
regulations as part of its power plant
emissions rules shares of arch coal
Peabody Energy and Alpha Natural
Resources all headed higher defying the
slump in the overall market now the rule
was designed to cut hazardous emissions
of mercury and acid gases from 460
coal-fired power plants and it has led
to the closing of dozens of power plants
over the last two years and joining me
now with more is alex steele good to see
you you see you at all right goodnight
so what this is all because of the
ruling the Environmental Protection
Agency did not consider the cost when
they looked at what this would do to the
coal industry which is billions and
billions and billions of dollars and
what was also so amazing about this
ruling is that coal stocks were having a
really bad time this has been a really
hard time for companies on the one hand
you have a fundamental transition where
you're moving from coal to natural gas
in terms of lectricity you also have
very cheap oil as well and alternative
energy is kind of roaring right now so
all in all actual demand for coal was
struggling and coal stocks have been so
unloved I mean they were just like the
Satan of stocks if you could say that
well there you go the sp500 coal and
consumer fuel index there we go down
51-percent and part of that is you have
a lot of pension funds like Norway
sovereign wealth fund saying we are not
going to buy a coal stocks anything with
more than best set divesting their
holdings of stocks that have more 30 or
percent or more of their earnings from
coal and that is utilities now that is
like the Duke Energy's no matter how
fast these companies try and diversify
this is still a big issue so it was kind
of they need a little bit of love we got
a little bit alone well and just to make
it clear that this ruling at the Supreme
Court now goes down back to a lower
court in order to figure out these rules
in the costs if you still need the
admission rules of course you still need
to move that forward as well so it mean
to figure out that fine line okay